[Música]
Olá, minhas amigas, meus amigos. Sejam
muito bem-vindos para mais uma
live. Lembrando a vocês que o link da
live sim fica
fixado, mas acho que algumas pessoas não
sabem utilizar essa funcionalidade do
WhatsApp. Então eu coloquei de novo o
link da
live agora nas mensagens. OK. Temos
poucas perguntas hoje, mas eu separei
três artigos interessantes pra gente
poder discutir, mas vocês também podem
estar fazendo as perguntas ao vivo, como
sempre, tá? Boa noite, Reinaldo. Boa
noite, Enildes. Vocês estão me ouvindo
bem? Me de feedback, por favor, do áudio
se
tá OK esse áudio, né? Me parece que tá
tudo em ordem aqui, mas eu queria a
confirmação de
vocês. Bem, primeiro artigo que eu,
aliás, artigo não, primeira pergunta que
eu vou responder, Enild e o Rinaldo
estão confirmando que o áudio está OK.
Primeira
pergunta que me mandaram é: "Doutor,
para quem faz reposição?" Aliás, deixa
eu mostrar na tela aqui a pergunta.
Ver se vai ficar bem assim. Acho que
vai. Fiz uma raspagem na próstata, pois
um certo dia não consegui urinar. O
urologista me disse que tem uma técnica
de aplicar botox na bexiga. Ele me disse
que melhora muito as idas ao banheiro
para urinar. Você conhece? Se sim, é
confiável. Sim, eu
conheço. Isso é uma técnica, já tem uns
10 anos mais ou menos que existe, tá?
Ã, é uma técnica assim que funciona
muito bem,
tá? Então, essa aplicação de botox na
bexiga, ela é já reconhecida há muitos
anos para tratar alguns problemas
urinários. Então ela é indicada
principalmente para caso de bexiga
hiperativa, que é uma situação que a
bexiga contrai fora de hora e
exageradamente, ou também é utilizado
para alguns tipos de incontinência
urinária de
urgência, que é uma situação que o
paciente ou a paciente sente uma vontade
controlável de urinar e não consegue
chegar ao banheiro a tempo. E também
pode ser utilizado o botox na bexiga
para pessoas que têm cistite
intesticial. Tem pacientes também com
doenças neurológicas que afetam o
controle da bexiga, que é o caso da
esclerose múltipla ou lesão medular.
E é indicada essa injeção de botox na
bexiga quando os tratamentos
medicamentosos, especialmente com uso de
anticolinéicos, né, ou uso também de
agonista beta, eh, não trazem um alívio
suficiente aos sintomas, OK?
Então o botox ele é aplicado diretamente
no músculo da bexiga, que a gente chama
de músculo detrusor e em vários pontos
na bexiga. São 30 pontos e através de
uma cistoscopia. Então tem que passar o
aparelho por dentro da uretra na bexiga
para poder fazer essas injeções no
músculo da
bexiga. Então o objetivo é paralisar
parcialmente o músculo da bexiga,
reduzindo as contrações involuntárias. E
assim, o objetivo é diminuir a urgência,
a frequência, os episódios de
incontinência urinária. E o efeito dessa
cirurgia, né, desse procedimento dura
entre 6 a 9 meses. Então é necessário
repetir depois desse período, tá? Então
ele é considerado um procedimento
confiável. Alguns estudos dizem que a
aplicação de botox na bexiga é eficaz e
a princípio
segura para ter esse controle de
sintomas em pacientes selecionados. O
importante é você fazer boa
seleção. Então, a taxa de sucesso é
considerado alta com relatos de melhora
em até 85% dos casos que são
refratários, ou seja, que não respondem
a outros tratamentos.
E é um procedimento já aprovado há
vários anos, né, pela Anvisa e por
outros órgãos internacionais de saúde.
Porém, tem os seus efeitos colaterais,
sim, como qualquer procedimento médico,
tem riscos e
potenciais efeitos adversos. Então, o
principal risco é infecção
urinária por causa, né, da questão da
retenção de urina. pode acontecer uma
retenção de urina leve e esse resíduo
urinário eh infectar causando infecção
urinária. E também pode acontecer que a
certenção urinária seja mais acentuada e
ser necessário o cateterismo vesical,
passar uma sonda vesical para esvaziar a
bexiga. Outros efeitos colaterais menos
frequentes são dor, sangramento leve no
local da aplicação, dificuldade para
urinar e raramente reações alérgicas.
Tá? Então, botox não é o
primeiro e procedimento indicado, né? A
primeira indicação para todos os tipos
de problemas
urinários. Por exemplo, botox não é útil
para incontinência urinária de esforço,
né? Que é quando a válvula não está
funcionando bem, quando a perda de urina
acontece por tosse, espirro ou levantar
peso. Então, para esse tipo de
procedimento, para esse tipo de
problema, não é o procedimento adequado,
OK? ou também não é o botox não é
adequado para pessoas
eh que fizeram a cirurgia de próstata
por obstrução, a não ser que esteja
comprovado que existe bichiga
hiperativa e que não tá relacionada à
obstrução, OK? Então, tomar cuidado só
com isso, porque tem que comprovar no
seu caso, se você de fato tá
desobstruído antes de indicar a injeção
de botox, tá? Porque se você tiver ainda
com algum grau de obstrução e essa
obstrução for a causa da frequência
urinária aumentada, isso
pode provocar aí problemas, tá?
Especialmente retenção urinária
piorar. Então tem que selecionar muito
bem o
paciente e porque pode acontecer
problemas, OK? E o urologista tem que
ter experiência na técnica.
Bem, tem mais uma pergunta. Acho que eu
pulei uma pergunta aqui. Tinham, tinham
duas perguntas aqui. Deixa eu voltar
aqui. É, e eu ah, já tem seis perguntas.
Fizeram pergunta de última hora aqui.
Próxima
pergunta. Doutor, para quem faz
reposição de T4, T3 pela manhã, quando
vai fazer um exame em laboratório para
medir T3, T4, deve ingerir a cápsula
normalmente e depois fazer o exame? ou
deve fazer o exame e depois ingerir a
cápsula. Fazer o exame primeiro e
ingerir a cápsula depois,
tá? Porque a questão é o seguinte,
eh o T3 ele tem uma meia vida no sangue
curta, tá? E ela vai subir rapidamente
depois de você tomar.
Então você tomar o T3 de manhã antes da
coleta pode causar um pico transitório
dos níveis no sangue, já que tem meia v
curta e rápida absorção. Isso pode levar
a resultados artificialmente altos e não
representativos do estado geral ou basal
do paciente,
tá? Que o objetivo do exame é tentar ver
o máximo possível estado geral o
equilíbrio hormonal estável e não o pico
pós dosagem, tá?
e recomenda-se evitar a ingestão também
de biotina. Biotina é uma vitamina, né,
que interfere com vários exames
hormonais, tá? Ou pelo menos 8 horas
antes do
exame. OK? Então essa que é a tua
resposta para tua
pergunta. Bem, tivemos várias perguntas
aí de última hora que eu não cheguei a
ver. Vamos lá.
aqui pergunta: se uma pessoa acorda às 5
horas da manhã, mas fica até 7 deitada e
às 7:30 toma sol, qual é o horário que o
circo é círculo, né? Não é círculo
círculo circadiano, aliás, é ciclo.
Ciclo
circadiano. Reconhece como
despertamento. Se ao se levantar, olhar
para o sol ali ocorre o ativamente o
ciclo se não é a hora que você abre os
olhos porque qualquer luminosidade que
entrar ali, mesmo que não seja o sol,
não seja luz natural, vai indicar já que
é dia, tá bom? Lógico que a luz do sol é
mais eficiente nisso, mas não quer dizer
se você não tiver contato com nenhuma
luz solar que o seu corpo não indicou
que você acordou,
tá? Se levantar no escuro, tá? Não vai
ser a mesma coisa que levantar com a
luz, tá? Porque aí o organismo vai
entender que você tá ainda no ciclo da
noite, tá?
Então, acordou no escuro ou o organismo
sabe que você tá ainda no horário
noturno. Se você acordou no claro, mesmo
com luz artificial, ele vai saber que
você já tá no período do dia. Só que a
luz solar é mais fisiológica nesse
sentido.
OK. Próxima pergunta. A medicina
integrativa tem tratamentos alternativos
e promissores para câncer?
Eh, então isso aí é uma pergunta muito
boa e vai depender também do que que
você considera medicina integrativa, né?
Porque assim, se você considera medicina
integrativa
fitoterapia, sim, tem vários
fitoterápicos que ajudam muito. Eh, eu
não recomendaria usar eles isoladamente,
sem tratamentos ortodoxos. Eu acho que
tem que fazer sim o tratamento ortodoxo
de reduzir massa tumoral, seja com
cirurgia, seja com rádioqumio. Porém tem
várias vitaminas aí, por exemplo,
estocotrienois ajudam de modo geral na
eficiência da químia e da
radioterapia. Isso é vitamina, não é
fitoterápico, mas tem vários outros
fitápicos e que ajudam bastante, né? O
visco álbum mesmo é um que é muito
utilizado para câncer, né? Mas tem
vários outros aqui, né? as próprias
vitaminas K2 tem feito anticâncer.
Ã, tem vários antioxidantes aí que, tipo
licopeno, asta chantina,
zeachantina que tem efeito anticâncer. A
lista é muito grande, eu não vou falar
tudo aqui porque nem é o caso, OK? Mas
eu diria que são alternativos e
promissores desde que utilizados em
conjunto com o tratamento
ortodoxo. Trat do câncer é sempre
multifatorial, nunca deve ser
considerado uma coisa só, uma linha só.
E eu tô avaliando também as alegações
ali do Dr. William Marques, o
oncologista canadense, com relação a
ivemectina e a o femazol.
A combinação dos dois também tem a
combinação de vimectina com
mebendazol. E tô
ainda os meus primeiros casos para
realmente ter certeza que essa
combinação, isso não é foterapia também,
não
é exatamente medicina integrativa, mas é
uso alternativo de drogas já
estabelecidas para o tratamento do
câncer, certo?
Tem também a o hidrogênio molecular, que
também pode ser parte da medicina
integrativa, que tem efeito bom contra o
câncer. Então tem muita coisa aí da
medicina alternativa que pode ajudar no
tratamento do câncer, mas eu não
recomendaria utilizar isoladamente, tá?
Mas sim em conjunto com
outras
estratégias. Qual a melhor maneira de
evitar os diversos tipos de cânceres? A
beberina pode prevenir? Sim. É um dos
fitoterápicos que eu a gente utiliza
como ação anticâncer, tá? Beberina, sim,
ele pode ajudar a prevenir e tratar
também. E a crimarina, a mesma coisa,
tá? Eles são
flavonoides. A bemina tem uma ação mais
intensa de bloqueio da MPK, né? E dessa
maneira
ela tem ação também de
antiproliferativo, né? E a sinimarina
também tem uma ação de câncer menos eh
intensa e também mais no sentido de
detox do fígado, mas certamente poderia
utilizar, poderia ajudar bastante, tá?
Eh, e na verdade os protocolos são bem
complexos, tá? Não é uma coisa ou outra,
não. São no mínimo 20 substâncias que a
gente usa para poder tentar ajudar nos
casos de câncer.
Existe alguma capa protetora que impede
a radiação do celular? Eh, tem algumas
vendidas aí no mercado, né? Eu,
particularmente não ponho minha mão no
fogo, tá? Eu não tenho certeza que essas
capas ou adesivos de fato funciona. Eu
lembro que até vendia lá quando eu fiz a
prova, prova não, fiz ali a formação com
o Dr. Laí Ribeiro, né? A
pós-graduação, tinha um pessoal lá que
vendia esses adesivos aí. O fato é que
eu nunca vi nenhum estudo comprovando
que isso realmente funciona, né? Eu
tenho minhas reservas quanto a isso,
então eu nem confirmo e nem
eh tenho certeza absoluta que não
funciona,
tá? Eu acho que o segredo em relação ao
celular é você ficar o mais longe
possível dele o possível, tá? Então, se
você tem que usar o celular no dia a
dia, deixa ele numa distância aí de 30,
cm e manipula ele o mínimo possível, tá?
Não deixa ele grudado na orelha. Se for
usar o celular, usa um fone de ouvido eh
de preferência com fio, tá? Pode usar o
sem fio, mas o sem fio também tem
radiação. Menos que você falar direto no
celular, mas também tem
radiação. Mas o ideal realmente é você
tentar usar o celular com um fone com
fio, tá? Eu acho que é melhor ou então
usar o ele como viva-vos, né? São
alternativas interessantes esses
bloqueadores, sinceramente, a a minha
impressão é que eles não funcionam,
apesar de não ter provas, nem que
funciona, nem que não
funciona. Ver as suas perguntas ao
vivo. Pergunta aqui da Inilde. Doutor, o
que que você acha do uso do canabidiol
para insônia? Eu acho muito
interessante. Eu tenho usado em vários
pacientes, tenho experiência sim e tenho
tido bons resultados. Mas eu nunca uso o
canabol como primeira opção para
insônia, não. Eu uso como alternativa
para casos resistentes, tá? Então, mas
sim, eu tenho tido uma boa experiência
do uso do canabidiol em conjunto com
melatonina, em alguns casos também com
uso de THC, os games de THC.
E a gente associa também outros agentes,
né, outros fitoterápicos usa eliteanina,
taurina, glicina, lisina, magnésio, HTP,
né, 5HTP.
Então tem uma série de recursos aí que a
gente pode utilizar em conjunto com o
canabidiol ou extrato de cannabis, FC,
broad Spectrum ou até os extratos que
têm predomínio aí de THC, THC um para um
para
canabol. Boa noite, Alice Vogel. Boa
noite Ana Reinaldo. Já tinha dado boa
noite, Enildo também. Você pode ser
usado para idoso, sem dúvida tem muito
idoso que usa. Inclusive o extrato de
cannabis é muito utilizado para
pacientes que têm doença
neurodegenerativa, né, Paxon e
Alzheimer. Então ele é totalmente viável
de ser
utilizado em idoso, sim. Tá, teria um
problema de usar em idoso. O que eu
teria muito cuidado é com criança, tá?
Eu só usaria extrato de cannabis em
criança em caso de
epilepsia, porque existe alguma suspeita
que o uso de produtos canábicos em
crianças pode causar problemas de
desenvolvimento na criança. Então, no
caso de uma epilepsia refratária, eu
acho justificável usar o extrato de
cannabis, mas para outras indicações,
eh, talvez no autismo. Autismo também eu
acho que seria
justificável usar o extrato de cannabis
além da epilepsia, mas eu evitaria de
usar o extrato de cânnabes em criança de
modo
geral, tá? A não ser que seja uma
situação aí que justifique o
risco, apesar de que eu não tenho a
certeza absoluta de que o estrato de
cannabis realmente é tão deletério assim
para o desenvolvimento infantil. Tem
alguns estudos falando que sim, mas
esses estudos eu acho que eles são mais
focados no uso recreativo do cannabis do
que no extrato, né, que é é um tanto
quanto diferente,
né? Bem, boa noite, Antônio Renato, seja
bem-vindo pra live. Bem, vamos
agora falar dos artigos,
tá? Mas aí vem a pergunta do Antônio
antes da gente falar dos artigos, né?
Você ainda indica o azeite herdade do
esporão? Indico até o momento que eu
tiver alguma
evidência, perdão, de que ele não é mais
um bom produto, tá?
Até o momento eu não tenho nenhum tipo
de evidência de que não é um produto de
boa qualidade. Se você tiver alguma
informação para dividir conosco de que
houve alguma situação com esse azeite,
por favor, não deixe falar,
né? Mas até onde eu sei, é um ótimo
azeite. Mas ninguém
tá eh livre, né, de ter problemas aí, ó.
Talvez o fabricante pode entrar numa
situação aí de querer economizar, de
querer ter lucro mais fácil e fazer
alguma bobagem,
né? Bem, primeiro artigo que eu queria
falar com
vocês é um artigo interessante sobre o
café da manhã, né? O desjejum. no
controle da açúcar do
sangue. Como é que então o café da manhã
poderia afetar ou influenciar os níveis
de açúcar no sangue, né? Será que vocês
pararam para
pensar, talvez o horário que você toma o
seu desjejum, seu café da manhã, pode
influenciar a maneira como é corpo
processa o almoço, né? É
uma situação interessante, né?
uma pesquisa recente com adolescentes
trouxe algumas descobertas interessantes
sobre essa situação. Então, vamos
conversar aqui se o horário que você
toma o café da manhã ou se você pula o
café da manhã tem alguma influência
sobre a glicemia ou açúcar no sangue pós
almoço. Então, trata-se de um estudo de
um grupo de 15 meninas, todas o sexo
feminino, adolescentes,
idade entre 12 a 14 anos, média de 13
anos, participaram de um experimento
científico. Então, em três dias
diferentes, elas seguiram rotinas
alimentares distintas, né? Num dia, por
exemplo, elas tomavam café da manhã bem
cedo, OK? não tão cedo assim, às 8:30 da
manhã, no outro dia tomava um café da
manhã mais tarde às 10:30 e no terceiro
dia elas simplesmente não tomavam café
da manhã, pulavam o café da manhã. Então
em todos os casos, elas almoçaram no
mesmo horário ao meioia e meia.
Então, o que aconteceu foi muito
interessante, né, nessa comparação entre
as três
situações. Os pesquisadores descobriram
que quando as adolescentes tomavam café
da manhã mais tarde, das 10:30 da manhã,
os níveis de glicose após o almoço eram
mais baixos, né? Então, comer o café da
manhã à tarde reduziu os níveis de
glicose após o almoço em 25%, um número
bem
significativo comparado com o café da
manhã cedo. E para quem pulou o café da
manhã, né, olha só,
36%, né, de redução pro grupo que tomou
o café da manhã tarde em relação ao
grupo que papulou o café da manhã, né?
Bem surpreendente isso, né?
Então, a pior situação aqui dos três
grupos foi pular o café da manhã. Quem
tomou café da manhã à tarde
teve um benefício bem
interessante, tá? em relação ao grupo
que tomou café da manhã cedo. Então, em
ordem de melhor para pior, tomar café da
manhã às 10:30, tomar café da manhã às
8:30 e não e pular o café da manhã, foi
a pior situação. Agora, gente, eh, quer
dizer que eu concordo 100% com isso? Eu
tô tô aqui discutindo um estudo que eu
acabo de
ler com vocês pra gente poder discutir
isso aqui, tá? Não é, quer dizer que
isso aqui é informação definitiva sobre
esse assunto, mas eu achei muito
interessante, por isso que eu quis
trazer para vocês,
né? Então, segundo esse estudo, um
simples ajuste no horário do café da
manhã teve impacto bem considerável nos
níveis de açúcar no sangue após o almoço
e nesse grupo de meninas adolescentes,
tá?
Então, segundo esse estudo, esse efeito
é explicado por um nome
chamado
fenômeno da segunda refeição. Então,
segundo eles eles dizem, eh estudos
mostram que tomar café da manhã em
comparação com pular a refeição pode
diminuir o aumento de glicose no sangue
após o
almoço. E os mecanismos que explicariam
esse fenômeno seriam primeiro, a redução
dos níveis de ácidos grassos livres
antes do
almoço, o aumento da síntese de
glicogênio muscular após o
almoço. E em pessoas que tm diavés tipo
dois, o café da manhã pode melhorar a
resposta da insulina ao almoço, tá?
Então, de novo, três explicações
possíveis. Redução dos níveis de ácidos
gráos livres antes do almoço. Para quem
tomou o café da manhã à tarde, tá?
Aumento da síntese de glicogênio
muscular após o almoço e em pessoas com
diabetes tipo 2, o café da manhã poderia
melhorar a resposta da insulina após o
almoço. OK?
Então eu na verdade o que que eu tenho
orientado meus pacientes que têm que
fazer jejum intermitente, especialmente
aqueles que têm défic cognitivo, estão
fazendo o protocolo recod. Eu peço para
não pular o café da manhã, mas já já
pedi isso antes de de ver esse estudo.
Eu peço para chão tá cedo fazer de 12 a
16 horas de jejum e fazer a primeira
refeição, tipo 9 da manhã ou 10 da
manhã. Eu já falava isso daí. Não, não
orientava especificamente a pular o café
da manhã.
OK? Então, eh, não é que você não deve
fazer o jejum intermitente, mas o time
no jejum parece que cada vez mais é
importante,
tá? Então, o timing do café da manhã faz
diferença
assim. Um intervalo de apenas 2 horas
entre o café da manhã e o almoço mostrou
mais benéfico do que você fazer um
intervalo de 4 horas ou até mesmo pular
o café da manhã, OK?
Então pode ser uma estratégia
interessante para pré-diabético ou
diabéticos. Primeiro que eu não
recomendo que façam o café da manhã rico
em carboidrato, pelo amor de Deus. Faça
o café da manhã com proteína e gordura
saudável e 2 horas depois almoce,
né? E aí é mais ou menos como se fosse
um aquecimento do metabolismo, tá? E
isso também não invalida, como eu falei,
você fazer jejum.
E óbvio, gente, que isso aqui também tem
que ser colocado no contexto do
individualismo, né? Nem todos respondem
da mesma maneira que os hábitos
alimentares regulares de cada pessoa
podem influenciar esse
efeito. Então, estudos mostram que
pessoas que habitualmente tomam café da
manhã, eh, de novo, isso aqui é a visão
do autor, tá? Apresentam maiores
benefícios desse fenômeno da segunda
refeição, tá? Então, por outro lado,
aqueles que raramente tomam café da
manhã podem não experimentar os mesmos
efeitos
positivos. Então, num estudo que nós
estamos discutindo, os adolescentes, no
caso as, né, que eram meninas, né, as
adolescentes participantes, não eram
habituadas a tomar café da manhã
regularmente. Então, elas naturalmente
apulavam o café da
manhã e só tomava esse café da manhã eh
cerca de duas vezes por semana.
Então, o café da manhã tardio trouxe
benefícios significativos, redução de
33% do açúcar do sangue em relação ao
pessoa, o pessoal que não tomou o café
da manhã,
certo? Então, de novo, não significa que
todo mundo tem que sempre tomar café da
manhã tarde para melhorar o controle
glicêmico, né? Porque a resposta não é
igual para todos, embora os estudos
mostrem de maneira consistente, segundo
esse
artigo, que tomar café da manhã,
especialmente tardio, melhora a resposta
glicêmica após o almoço, as pesquisas
sobre esse assunto ainda são limitadas,
tá? e especialmente a benefícios a longo
prazo. Alguns estudos com duração de
várias semanas não encontraram
diferenças significativas nas medidas de
controle glicêmico entre pessoas que
tomavam ou pulavam o café da manhã.
Então, teve já estudos falando ao
contrário que não teve diferença quem
pulou ou não pulou o café da manhã, tá?
Então existe sim situações, situações,
mas tem que ficar com isso em mente que
tem pessoas que podem se
beneficiar de tomar o café da manhã
tardio e 2 horas depois almoçar. Isso
pode reduzir o índice glicêmico, não
índice glicêmico, mas a glicemia pós
refeição do
almoço. OK? Porém, eu acho que muito
mais importante do que isso é você fazer
um café da manhã com proteína e gordura
de qualidade, reduzir o carboidrato e a
mesma coisa com o almoço, tá? E cada
pessoa é uma pessoa. Os hábitos
alimentares individuais, o metabolismo
individual é muito importante ainda, tá?
Próximo artigo que queria discutir com
vocês é um
estudo sobre os probióticos, os efeitos
desses probióticos na diabetes ou no
diabetes tipo 2,
tá? Já respondo sua pergunta, tá,
Antônio Renato?
Então, houve uma descoberta que pod
casar novas esperanças para pessoas com
diabetes tipo
2. Então, estudaram o efeito dos
probiótos, né, as chamadas bactérias do
bem ou bactérias benéficas no controle
do diabetes. Então, esse estudo recente
trouxe resultados interessantes sobre
esse tema.
Então, um grupo de 124 homens e mulheres
com idade média de 57 anos, todos com
diabetes tipo 2 e durante 24 semanas,
praticamente 6 meses, metade deles tomou
cápsulas contendo 14 tipos diferentes
probióticos. Então, era um blend bem
diversificado de probióticos, enquanto a
outra metade do grupo tomou apenas
vitamina B12, que é o grupo controle,
tá? Então, o que que os pesquisadores
queriam então tirar dessa desse
estudo? Se os probióticos poderiam
trazer benefícios para pessoas com
diabetes tipo 2, especialmente em
relação ao envelhecimento celular e
inflamação. Então, o que que aconteceu
nessas 24
semanas? Primeiro, os participantes que
tomaram probióticos tiveram menor
encurtamento de telômero, tá? que é
aquela pontinha dos cromossomos, que é
um é um dos indicadores de
envelhecimento,
né? Então, são essas capinhas
protetoras, pensa num cadaço
de tênis, né? Aquela pontinha do
cadastro geralmente tem um plástico, né,
duro, que é para você poder passar o
cadaço e pelos buracos lá do tênis, né?
Então, o telômero seria essa capinha
igual tem no cadastço do tênis, tá?
A medida que
envelhecemos, essas pontinhas
estelômeros, eh, vão naturalmente
ficando mais
curtos e o encurtamento é um dos
marcadores de envelhecimento celular. E
quanto menos
encamento, menos envelhecimento celular
você tá
tendo. Outro marcador também que reduziu
como probiótico foi a proteína C
reativa, que é um conhecido marcador de
inflamação no organismo. É um dos que a
gente mais pede no consultório de exame
para checar inflamação geral. Então,
menos inflamação, melhor saúde e mais
sobrevida.
E o terceiro marcador que foi encontrado
também e talvez o mais importante no
caso do diabetes é os níveis de
hemoglobina glicada. Então, houve menos
níveis de biomoglobina glicada nos
diabéticos que tomaram probióticos, né,
que é o melhor marcador mais importante
aí para o controle do açúcar ao longo do
tempo, que ele retrata os últimos 90
dias de controle do açúcar ou controle
glicêmico.
Então os probióticos, como eu disse,
foram 14 tipos, incluíram gêneros
lactobacilos, bifobactérium,
estreptococos e uma levedura que é o
sacaromices. Então, geralmente os
probióticos que a gente toma aí eh na
maioria dos lugares que a gente obtém na
manipulação ou na internet não tem tanta
cepa assim,
tá? E cada cápsula dessa formulação
probiótica tinha 30 bilhões de unidades
de colônia.
que é um número bem
expressivo, né? Então aqui a gente tem
no Brasil, a grande maioria dos produtos
tem menos de 30 bilhões, né? Tem os 20
bis aí da vida, mas 30 bilhões não é tão
fácil, né? Agora fora do Brasil é mais
fácil encontrar essas cepas muito
grandes aí de probióticos.
Então, esses são resultados promissores,
porém são resultados ainda iniciais, tá?
E temos que considerar algumas
limitações. Em primeiro lugar, os
cientistas analisaram o efeito sobre os
telômeros. eles não ajustaram os
cálculos para múltiplas
comparações, eh, que é o caso em estudos
mais
rigorosos, se tivessem feito o ajuste,
né, de múltiplas comparações, os
resultados poderiam ser diferentes,
poderiam não ter atingido o que nós
chamamos de significância estatística,
tá?
Então, a esse efeito de significância
estatística é o efeito que a gente busca
para entender se de fato aquele agente,
aquela intervenção que foi feita de se
ela foi realmente eh um efeito
significativo,
tá? Que às vezes pode ser um efeito eh
simulado e não
significativo. E tem outro detalhe
importante, né? O grupo de controle
recebeu vitamina B12 e a B12 por si só
poderia já causar efeitos positivos na
saúde e pode ter tido até um efeito
protetor em relação aos telômeros, que
algumas pesquisas dizem que a B12 pode
ter esse
efeito. Então, se o estudo tivesse usado
placebo de verdade, né, pílula de
farinha como controle, a diferença entre
os grupos poderia ter sido
diferente. Então, o que que esse estudo
significa na prática para pessoas com
diabetes tipo dois, né? Então que sim, a
gente pode experimentar essa estratégia
para os diabéticos como uma terapia
secundária ou terciária. Creio que não
custa nada, mas ainda não
temos uma certeza absoluta de que que de
fato o probiótico vai ajudar no controle
gliccêêmico ou até em aumentar a
longevidade. Há evidência suficiente
para considerar que os probióticos em
pessoas com diabetes tipo 2 tem um
aparente triplo benefício, né? Uma
redução do envelhecimento celular, uma
diminuição da inflamação e melhora do
controle glicêmico, tá? Então, todos os
efeitos são desejáveis que poderiam
teoricamente complementar os tratamentos
convencionais. Então eu realmente acho
interessante introduzir nos diabéticos
ou pré-diabéticos os probióticos, se
tiver espaço para esse
tratamento. Porém, importante lembrar
que esse é apenas um estudo e tem que
ser confirmado por outros estudos
maiores, né, em estudos, isso é um
desafio, né, para coisas naturais, como
vocês bem sabem, né, porque não existe
tanta incentivo, né,
para e pesquisas
grandes. Bem, deixa eu pergun responder
a pergunta aqui do Antônio
Renato. Como medicina
integrativa lida com esses artigos
científicos que homens dizem uma coisa e
amanhã já desmentem tudo? Então, Antônio
Renato, eh hoje em dia a gente tem uma
situação cada vez mais comum, que as
pessoas não toleram, né,
o o controverso, né, as pessoas não
toleram eh visões antagônicas, né? Eu
sei que isso deixa as pessoas muito
confusas, visões antagônicas, mas a
ciência é feita dessa maneira.
A ciência é feita com várias visões
antagônicas, eh, discutindo entre si até
que a gente chega num consenso depois de
muito tempo, tá? Isso incomoda muita
gente e incomoda mais
ainda hoje em dia que tá todo mundo
muito eh fadado a a ser radical numa
posição, né? A ser a a assumir uma um
posicionamento e não largar mais esse
posicionamento, né? As pessoas hoje em
dia estão muito polarizadas pela
política, pela questão da formação de
bolhas nas redes sociais. Então eu
entendo a confusão que vocês estão
falando e não entenda isso que eu tô
falando com uma crítica a você, Antônio.
Não é isso. Mas a ciência é mutável, ela
muda o tempo todo, tá? É óbvio que se eu
ler um artigo falando que o ômega-3 dá
fibrilação atrial, aumenta o risco de
fibrilação atrial, eu vou ler com muito
cautela e com
muito pé atrás, como eu já li
recentemente um artigo falando isso, mas
a gente tem que pegar essa informação e
aceitar ela de uma maneira mais
tranquila e não ficar revoltado,
entende? E realmente tem outros estudos
falando o contrário disso. Então a gente
tem que usar o bom senso para eh ver
qual das visões a gente vai adotar. Por
exemplo, ômega-3 é uma coisa que eu
tenho muita convicção que faz bem pro
organismo. Então se eu vejo um estudo
falando mal de
ômega-3, eu não vou descartar esse
estudo, mas também eu não vou acreditar
nele prontamente, tá? Então a gente tem
que saber lidar com informações
contraditórias de uma maneira mais
tranquila, tá? de maneira
mais eh madura, tá? Porque hoje em dia
realmente as pessoas estão sendo muito
empurradas para pro radicalismo,
né? Se uma pessoa for furada com agulha
contaminada com a ides, quanto tempo
para evitar? Ela pode tomar um protocolo
eh chama e quimioprofilaxia, tá? Você
pode tomar um um coquetel antiviral.
Se eu não me engano, são 14 dias. Eu eu
até uma vez eu me furei com a agulha
contaminada, com HIV, quando eu tava na
residência médica de cirurgia geral.
Isso faz
já mais de 20 anos, né? Eu tô fumado há
27 anos na residência de cirurgia geral.
É mais ou menos
uns 26 anos atrás, 25 anos
atrás foi quando aconteceu isso. E eu
tomei uns 14 dias de protocolo de
quimioprofilaxia, nunca tive problema,
tá? Não, não sei se hoje em dia tá ainda
14 dias, porque eu não li mais sobre o
esse
assunto. Você disse que pelo bem do
intestino não devemos comer após as 6
horas. 6 horas do quê? da
tarde, mas para quem forma às 9, dá
tempo de invasar o intestino. Qual seria
a hora ideal? Invazar o
intestino. Eu não entendi isso aqui,
Antônio. Não, o artigo, se você tá
falando do artigo que eu falei agora, o
artigo que tá falando café da manhã não
tem nada a ver com o negócio do
intestino, tá?
Não sei se eu entendi o que você tá
perguntando. Qual o melhor detox para
células cancerígenas? Não tem um detox
só. É um, são vários protocolos
diferentes, tá? Mas a si marina ele é
ele é muito bom para fígado, modo
geral. Não, eu dei minha opinião,
Antônio também. Não, não, não entenda
isso como uma crítica a você que não
foi, tá?
Eh, você pode reformular essa pergunta
aqui, Antônio, tá? Enquanto isso, eu vou
apresentar para vocês o último artigo do
dia. Por acaso é saúde intestinal, né? E
tem a ver com o butirato de sódio, tá?
O butirato de
sódio é um derivado de um ácido grasso
cadeia curta, né, que é o ácido
butírico, né, que é uma gordura de
cadeia curta que tem um papel muito
importante na saúde intestinal. Então,
vamos falar sobre uma descoberta
científica que pode trazer boas
notícias para mulheres na pós-menopausa.
Então, esse aqui é o estudo de mulheres
na
pós-menopausa. Você já deve ter ouvido
falar do ácido butírico ou butirato
sódio. Eu falei em vídeos anteriores,
né? E hoje tem um suplemento de
tributirina.
São três moléculas de
butirato. Então, o butirato ele é
produzido naturalmente pelas bactérias
intestinais quando fermentam
fibras e ele tem um efeito promissor na
saúde intestinal e surpreendentemente
também na força muscular, tá? É isso que
eu achei interessante nesse
artigo. O estudo recente
relevelou conexões fascinantes entre a
saúde intestinal e o desempenho fixo,
desculpa, desempenho físico. Então,
vamos explorar juntos o que que esse
estudo
mostrou e como isso pode impactar
milhões de mulheres aí na
pós-menopausa. Então, foram 146 mulheres
estudadas na
pós-menopausa com idade média de 20,
desculpa, idade média de 55 anos e
participaram de um estudo científico por
12 semanas. Então, metade delas recebeu
570 mg de butirato sódio diariamente,
enquanto a outra metade recebeu apenas
um placebo, que é a pílula de farinha,
tá? Então, os
pesquisadores queriam descobrir se o
botirato de sódio poderia melhorar a
saúde intestinal dessas mulheres e se
isso teria algum impacto na saúde
física, na força física e no desempenho
motor. Então, eles queriam saber se
existia uma conexão entre intestino e
músculo. Então, os resultados foram
interessantes, foram intrigantes. As
mulheres que tomaram o butirato de sódio
apresentaram redução dos níveis de
zonulina. Que que é zonulina? Ela é uma
molécula que participa da barreira
intestinal, tá? Então, quando a zonulina
do sangue tá alta ou do intestino tá
alta, significa que essa molécula tá
sendo perdida, né? E isso significa que
a barreira intestinal está sendo
comprometida, tá? Então, a zonolina é
essa proteína que regula as junções
entre as células, né? As tight junction
são as células do
intestino. E quando tá a zonina tá alta,
que tá perdendo zonulina, seja na nas
feeses ou no sangue. E quando a zonina
tá alta, isso tá associado a aumento da
permeabilidade intestinal, né? quando o
intestino vaza, né, deixa passar
moléculas inteiras pelo revestimento
intestinal, isso gera problemas de
saúde. Então, entra, inclusive
substâncias desejáveis paraa corrente
sanguínea intestinal.
Então, as mulheres que tomaram essa
trib, desculpa, não é tributirina, esse
estudo foi feito com butirato sódio. O
que eu conheço aqui no Brasil mais é o a
tributirina, que é o suplemento. Então,
as mulheres tomaram o butirato sódio,
tiveram melhorias na força de prensão
manual, que é a força que a gente usa
para apertar os objetos com as mãos e
também na função física geral em
comparação com o estudo, o início do
estudo. aumentaram a força da prevensão
manual e aumentaram a função física
geral. Então, os pescadores, os
pescadores descobriram uma correlação
que quanto maior a redução na
perabilidade intestinal, maiores eram as
melhorias na força de prensão, na
velocidade da caminhada e na função
física geral.
Então existe sim, assim como tem a
conexão intestino cérebro, né, o eixo
intestino cérebro, existe um eixo
intestino sistema muscular, tá? Como é
que funciona essa
conexão? Por que que o intestino mais
saudável levaria a músculos mais fortes?
E uma teoria sugere que quando o
revestimento intestinal tá vazando, né,
tá o liquigut, tá com excesso de
permeabilidade, as bactérias intestinais
e as toxinas poderiam entrar na corte
sanguínea, causando inflamação em todo o
organismo, inclusive nos músculos. E
essa inflamação poderia prejudicar a
função muscular e acelerar a perda de
massa muscular, um problema comum no
envelhecimento, especialmente na
menopausa. Então, o buttirato de
sódio, ele fortalece a barreira
intestinal, reduz o vazamento e
consequentemente protege os músculos dos
efeitos inflamatórios das bactérias
intestinais que alcançam a corrente
sanguínea, né? seria como consertar as
rachaduras de uma
parede, impedindo que invasores
indesejados entrem e causem
danos. E nós sabemos que após a
menopausa, muitas mulheres experimentam
perda de massa muscular, perda de massa
óssa e perda de força, que pode afetar
significativamente a qualidade de vida,
especialmente aumentando o risco de
fraturas, né, e também risco de quedas.
Se o butirato sódeo pode ajudar a
preservar a função muscular, a força
muscular e a questão física, isso
poderia representar uma possível
estratégia para envelhecer com mais
saúde e
autonomia. Então, temos que observar
que, embora o butirato sódio tenha
melhorado resultados em comparação com o
início do estudo, o estudo não
especificou claramente se essas
melhorias foram estatisticamente
significativas.
quando comparados ao placebo, tá? Então
não teve essa informação com
clareza. Então temos que interpretar
esses resultados com
cautela. E como obter então o butirato
de maneira natural, tá? O seu corpo
produz butirato quando as bactérias
intestinais fermentam algumas fibras
prebióticas, tá?
Issa situação acontece quando o corpo
processa a fibra da banana, da cebola,
do alho, dos grãos integrais, da aveia,
leguminosas como feijão e lentilha e
vegetais ricos em amido resistente, que
é o caso, por exemplo, da banana que
ainda não adoreceu totalmente, é o caso
da
batata doce ou batata inglesa cozida que
depois foi resfriada. Então, consumir
esses alimentos pode ajudar a aumentar
naturalmente a produção de butirato no
intestino e também tomar probióticos e
alimentos fermentados podem
ajudar. OK?
Então, se você é uma mulher na
pós-menopausa, considere aumentar o seu
a sua ingestão de fibras prebióticas
dessas que eu comentei aqui. Isso vai
ajudar na força
muscular. Ué. Ah, tá
pronto. Hã. Você disse que pelo bem do
intestino não devemos comer nada após as
6 horas da noite. Ah, tá. Mas quem dorme
às 9, dá tempo de esvaziar o intestino
em apenas 3 horas? Dá, dá tempo sim. Tá
bom. Dorme mais cedo, tenta jantar mais
cedo. São 3 horas, tá? O limite de tempo
entre você comer e dormir idealmente,
tá? 3 horas. O 3 horas paraa frente, né?
Bem, pessoal, temos já 50 minutos, quase
50 minutos de live. Já apresentei três
artigos para vocês. Vocês têm perguntas
em relação aos estudos que eu
apresentei? Eu vou ficar mais 2 minutos
e depois a gente encerra, tá bom?
De nada,
Antônio. De
nada. Quando der 50 minutos, eu vou
encerrar. São 49 minutos e 20 segundos
agora.
Obrigado pelo comentário, Enild. Às
vezes eu fico na dúvida se os artigos
que eu trago para vocês é de interesse
mesmo, tá? Eu tento trazer o que eu acho
mais interessante e mais relevante para
vocês, tá? De novo, não são artigos
definitivos,
né? Ah, deixa eu experimentar aqui uma
ferramenta nova aqui
do desse Streamyard
aqui. Ah, tá.
Eles estão colocando agora os
comentários aqui do lado, mas fica bem
pequenininho,
né? É, mas fica bem pequenininho isso
daqui, mas vamos deixar assim mesmo.
Obrigado, Rinaldo. Boa noite para você
também e sucesso para você também, tá?
Pessoal, muito obrigado aí pela
audiência. Lembrando a todos aí, vocês
comentem lá no grupo, por favor. Quem
não participa da dos vídeos ao vivo,
consegue assistir depois. no tempo
apropriado, quando quiser, tá? Não é
porque não participou ao vivo que eu não
consegue assistir depois. Vocês sabem
disso, mas é importante tá ressaltando
isso. Um abraço, um beijo no coração de
vocês. Até a próxima.